bismillah alhamdulillah Salam alaikum
peace be with you thank you for tuning
in to the Deen show this week we're
gonna be discussing a man who was sent
as a mercy for all of mankind now many
of you out there might have ambivalent
feelings towards this individual some of
you have watched the show and you agree
with with what's in your very nature
that there's nothing worthy of worship
except the creator of the heavens and
earth and now there is another piece to
that testimony that Muhammad was the
last and final messenger sent to mankind
a prophet just like Jesus
Abraham Moses and all the other messages
that were sent some of the more serious
people in life are getting a little bit
tired and they're looking for a purpose
the purpose of life and they've come to
Islam seeking this because all the other
man-made religions out there they just
don't make sense but they're just stuck
at this very important part so now we're
going to be discussing a little bit
helping you understand to help you
develop a clear understanding about who
this man was and then at the end God
willing you'll conclude is over 1.5
billion people closer to actually even
over that have concluded that this man
indeed was a messenger sent by the
creator of the heavens on earth
how many peace be upon him so don't go
anywhere we'll be right back to discuss
this very important topic here on the
Deen show
he's deal with you
how are you shake thank you for being
with us again here on the Dean show so
it was a pleasure to be here I'm always
a pleasure having you and as I open up
the program we talked about somebody
could have just been tuning in because
they're taking a religion class and many
people have come to Islam by taking a
religious class and they come to Islam
that topic and then they see like hey
the Islam makes sense
Islam is something that's rational
logical but also there is a lot of
misconceptions but people can't agree
you know when we give them the truth
that there is nothing worthy of worship
except the Creator many people almost
all of them they agree to that but now
there's the other part of it that
Muhammad is indeed the Messenger of God
and that would include all the preceding
messengers correct Jesus Moses Abraham
all of them this is correct shape so
tell us how important is this you know
this topic that we're talking about
before we get into studying the life of
the last I final messenger so people can
be be convinced that he indeed was a
mercy sent to the world how important is
this topic that we're talking about I'm
the last author so Allah for those who
believe that there is no one worthy of
worship except Allah but before that
even as human beings we believe that
everybody they have in themselves in
their innate nature that the creator of
the heavens and the earth is one
provided a sustained and so on but they
needed the messengers to be sent to call
the people to worship the creator of the
heavens in here and that's what was the
job of the messengers from one messenger
to the other the messengers they were
sent to the people to call them to
worship the creator of the heavens and
the earth alone so they human beings
that are in need of this more than they
need the food and the drink and life
itself so from one messenger to the
other messengers were sent
other people to their tribe and the
final messenger mohammed sallu narnia
seldom lost panatela sent him to our
mankind so the difference between him
and those who before him his message has
to be very comprehensive has to be
perfect and people can examine them and
also it has to be there for the rest of
this life that we live in till the day
of judgement saved no distortions in it
no change in it whatsoever that's why
there is no need for another messenger
to come and this is what we see in the
life of the Prophet SAW said Allah we
would see the best human being ever
worked on the face of earth the role
model for every human being
the messengers before you won't get
enough information about their life but
if you are a religious person if you are
a husband if you are untrained you you
buy and sell you want when we play many
roles in our life you're a child you're
grown up here whatever position whatever
situation that we're in we can have the
best example in the life of Prophet
Muhammad's online asylum and this is how
a lot of the Most High saved his whole
entire life for us for people to examine
that if they want to examine and also
for for those who believe to imitate him
and to follow him in every single thing
in major minor issues in all
relationships and everything that's the
beauty of it that makes sense that makes
sense because I mean your PC comes in an
instruction manual your Mac computer
comes with an instruction manual I mean
but the human beings more complex than
any of these things so it would make
sense of the crater would send us an
instruction manual and with the best of
examples so this is what we want to do
today we want to get into the life of
the last and final motion let's talk
about him briefly we have a lot of
points to cover before before he was
commissioned by the Creator because
obviously people can see like hold on
you know if people are intelligent they
look at his life they can see if this is
not something is absurd you know this
was somebody who there's no way that he
could have been a messenger from God
he's making his stuff so hopefully after
we go over these these these small
points didn't get it they get kind of a
good feel and it would further them to
look further into it so let's talk about
him before he was a prophet the prophet
sallallaahu salem and this is
also we should encourage everyone to
read about his life before he was sent
as a messenger his life before was such
in a way preparing him to be the
messenger to be the final Messenger of
Allah he did not know that he is being
prepared for this he was illiterate so
that the America that was given to him
which is a miraculous book of Allah
Spano to honor the words of Allah span
and to Allah that nobody can ever bring
the like of one line of it right and
even though he was not able to read and
write but he was given this but most
importantly one important thing because
at the time you know the Prophet peace
be upon him before he was sent
he was famously called Assad that LME
the truthful one and the one that is
trustworthy when you look into the life
of the Arabs Arabs at the time if you
have people that are a bunch of liars
right and someone in the midst of them
and he is very honest and truthful that
sticks out right now if we would see
that he's honest it wasn't the case for
the Prophet SAW sending these people
they were truthful people meaning they
would never lie they would never say a
lie and there are evidences of this one
of this there's a long hadith of Abu
Sufyan when he met with here Achilles
and one of the things that he said
because the the king of Romans he was
asking this man and he was not a Muslim
yet and he was an enemy to the Prophet
and they were in war with the Prophet
peace be upon him he asked him certain
questions to examine and to see how the
Prophet is because they had in the
prophecies that the Prophet is about to
come so the questions that he asked him
he answered the questions in a very
beautiful way talking about the Prophet
SAW said I'm in a very fair and just way
exposing all the good things of the
Prophet SAW said him when he's his enemy
and he said I cannot lie if it wasn't
for the people with me I would have
liked they used to consider lying as a
disastrous thing so having people like
this and to have the Prophet SAW said
them among them before being a messenger
and they were called him a Sadiq the
truthful one he has to be super super
truthful person so when immediately he
was sent area so toes that haven't
called them to worship allah subhana wa
ta'ala alone when people accepted this
for me
because he is someone that never speaker
line and the life was in such a way that
he was in doing trade and so on but he
was very honest and truthful people will
trust him with his wealth and and the
best manners even before he was sent as
a messenger so this was the the ruler of
Rome at that time her Acula so people
can go look look this up right so he had
a statement to say he kind of he kind of
knew they were anticipating weren't they
right a prophet to come and see the
whole world at the time were waiting for
a prophet to come the whole world the
whole world meaning the Christian world
and the Jude and the Jews were and
everyone and because of the prophecies
in the books before and that's why he
record is he was knowledgeable in his
book and he was waiting for them for a
prophet to come and when he heard that
someone claims to be a prophet or they
heard about the prophecy of the Prophet
SAW said Allah and one of his relatives
were in in Syria making the trade and so
on and he called them and he answered
specific questions asking specific
questions that from their book whether
his lineage what he's calling you to do
is he betraying you or not and things
like this and the question of the the
lying and so on I was offensive
something interesting before he was not
a Muslim he wreckless asked him does he
betray the people does he betray you he
said we are in a treaty with him now and
we're not sure whether he is going to
break it or not Abu Sufyan II said this
was the only pass that I can say because
everything else it shows them to be the
best man ever
so and even this Abu Sufyan this way
this person at that time who we know
later accepted Islam at that time so
this is only the way I can get him like
right this is the only way that it's
nothing it's nothing I like and then
later he accepted Islam except this
letter he was an enemy of Islam at that
time and he only listed good qualities
about the Prophet and he recognized
himself at the end he said if I was with
him I would watch what's underneath his
foot okay this is very important so her
accolades the Emperor said if he was
with the Prophet picture he would wash
his feet right he realized immediately
but this is the messenger that they've
been waiting for
uh-huh and that's why by the way if you
look at the map of how where the Muslims
went at the time or after that
the prophets Ursula this was for example
the chamfer Palestine Syria this was the
Christian world and Egypt and so on
people entered into the fold of Islam in
masses yeah people were being taught
that there's a messenger is about to
come you know any for example in the
churches and so on people have been
taught there's a messenger is about to
come
and once the prophets are settle them
and they get to know the prophets are
certain people except it is Lebanon
masses masses this is amazing it's
amazing so we're gonna take a break and
we'll come back with more here on the
Deen show I started asking deeper
questions the question I want people to
really ask themselves is when you come
back from a night on the town
you've been drinking you've been boozing
you've been dancing then you hanging out
with girls guys or whatever number one
did you improve yourself is human being
number two did you contribute anything
to the betterment of humanity the
amazing thing is is that the most
advanced studies in psychology
about human happiness show that these
are the two key factors in making people
profoundly happy I take five minutes out
of my day and prayed to the Creator and
none of the creations and I feel a deep
internal peace and I still have my
normal life back here on the Dean show
and we're talking about the last and
final messenger sent to mankind it makes
sense that the Creator who created
mankind the maker of mankind would send
an instruction man and he did he sent it
with Jesus peace be upon him did Jesus
ever call people to worship himself or
did he ever say he was that explicitly
say that I'm the son of God never and
there's nobody ever can bring the proof
of this whatsoever something that's
supposed to be a principle of faith
should be very well known very well
established with evidence and so and so
on there's not even one evidence clear
not ambiguous very explicit message from
Jesus peace be upon him that he would
call people to worship him and not the
Creator there is I wasn't there a
Christian king that the Muslims they
emigrated because they were being
tortured and persecuted and boycotted I
mean the the worst of the worst was
happening to him the same persecution
that the true followers of Jesus did may
go under the same ridicule and
persecution they were fed to the dogs
that Rome was lit up by them they were
made like fire cannibals you know and so
much so many atrocities to those people
who are true believers in the one God
now didn't the the the King at that time
he actually was a Christian but he
wasn't one who believed in a Trinity he
believed in one guy later he accepted
his Islam isn't is true he talked about
this that's the kingdom every senior and
the JC in English yes he was a Christian
and he was in Abyssinia and the Prophet
peace be upon him when the people in
Mecca they were so much persecuted and
hurt and tortured and so on he ordered
the weak among them those who did not
have a support in Mecca to migrate to
Abyssinia and the prophets peace be upon
him he said there's a just ruler there
go there and stay there till the matter
becomes better so when they went there
and the people of Kailash the
disbelievers they sent after them some
of the people to convince the King to
take them back and to continue to
prosecute them so when the believers
when the companions are the prophets
unless seldom they met this King and
they explained to him who they are and
what the prophets are seldom is
immediately this person he said this is
the final message this is the Messenger
of God this is the one that comes after
Jesus peace be upon him and he accepted
the religion of understand and when he
died in Abyssinia the Prophet peace be
upon him II pray to Allah to janaza
appeared the funeral prayer on him in
Medina because he died in the state of
Alistair he accepted Islam immediately
because again they were waiting for the
Prophet SAW said Allah they get to know
his qualities that it's mentioned in the
books and he actually I mean when the
Jaffa ready law and when his companion
of the Prophet peace be upon him when he
was asked about Islam you know what you
guys believe you know this was a
Christian king at that time What did he
say about the difference between us and
he to prove this point he illustrated
with the twig with Ali branch was
something very very small right and he
mentioned that their life before they
were just people of ignorance and
forgetfulness and they would kill each
other and they would you know fight with
each other and then lost parent I'll I
sent from from someone that is among
them from one of them the prophets are
the lawyers and I'm ordering them to
worship Allah subhanAllah
I don't to be kind to the to the kin and
kith and to feed the poor and to do what
is righteous and to establish the praise
and so on so Allah spinel Tyra
transformed their life from the life of
ignorance to the life of knowing the
purpose of their life and worshipping
the creator of the heavens and earth and
being kind to others and so on so they
when when he heard this and he heard the
message that this is from the Prophet
SAW said let me immediately accepted he
accepted a that's a man he was he was a
Christian who didn't believe now a lot
of these beliefs that just don't make
sense because none of the
prophets taught that a man is God or
that you know the creator had a literal
son can we say that you know back then
if they used the word son of God this
was someone who was close to God a pious
person right and that's what's actually
mentioned that there everybody all the
righteous people are sons of God in the
sense that this is not a physical not
nothing it's just a matter of being
righteous and so on yeah and actually by
the way most of the the Christian world
at the time they were in the true belief
of Jesus peace be upon like the people
in Egypt and so on many of them they
were under tongue heat on the oneness of
worship and the pure monotheism yes
because I mean when we have people I
don't want to go too deep into this but
when you really stop and think of people
they just say son of God some of that
but when you stop and think it just
doesn't make sense because we know cats
have kittens dogs had puppies what does
God have a baby God so you have two gods
now you have something that's just way
out there doesn't make sense and what
happened to the people before Jesus
peace be upon you what was the religion
of Abraham peace be upon he didn't know
the right God to worship he was
worshiping the one in the heavens -
that's it that's it yeah that's why
there's no such a thing as an invention
that all of a sudden people realized
there's something new it's the same
thing for every messenger yeah and
that's why when you would not find that
a more perfect way to believe in all the
messengers of Allah all of them from
Adam and Noah Abraham and Moses and
Jesus Prophet Muhammad SAW said Allah
except in this true and beautiful way of
life otherwise you're inventing your own
religion with your own belief and prove
it and there's no proof whatsoever oh
yeah I can keep going I want to stick to
this because I get sidetracked sometimes
so let's I'm gonna go back to some
examples let's talk about briefly
because I have so much to cover in this
short amount of time how did that so we
said okay before prophethood he was
given the title the DM of the Saudis was
the truthful trustworthy he had a
impeccable character even before
prophethood he never dated never drank
alcohol never worship sticks stones or
bones he was on the way of Abraham right
now the angel Gabriel comes from how did
this happen this has happened when the
Prophet before he was sent as a
messenger he was made beloved to him to
sit
himself and he would go right outside
the skirts of Mecca and be in a cave
there in the mountain worshipping Allah
I don't worshiping the true God the God
of Abraham and he would take with him
the provisions and the food and so on
from his wife Khadijah and he would go
there stays for days and then whenever
his provisions ends he would go back and
get some more and seclude himself in one
of these nights
the angel Gabriel Gabriel he came down
to him while he's in the cave and the
Prophet SAW seldom he did not know
what's what's happening and he gets
scared and worried but then indeed real
he took him and embraced him very hard
and pressed him and he said read the
echo and the Prophet SAW said oh it was
illiterate he said man I recall I cannot
read him that illiterate person and then
he did that for three times and then he
recited the verse the first verses that
was ever revealed to the Prophet SAW
suffer from the Quran which is a clubby
smell of bacon ready holla holla concern
I mean Arabic and a column and let the
under my we'll call him an 11 in sedima
nanum the first word was a claw read
write which is by the way has a great
significant this religion the miracle of
the last Messenger of Allah something to
state them to their judgment for people
to read which is the Book of Allah and
reminding the human beings that they
were created from a dirty drop and they
need to humble themselves to the creator
and heavens and earth and not to feel
that they are independent that they need
him because they are in need of him with
every breath I take I want to get this
and we got one minute before we have to
go to break
he goes to his wife and now he what
happens with his wife he went to his
wife and he was very scared what is this
he didn't make some grandiose story
right he told her what happened and he
said I'm afraid for myself and she
immediately had these out of the Alana
she did get scared like him but she said
level lie by Allah he would never
disgrace you meaning Allah would never
disgrace you why because she had an
evidence because you are someone that
feed the poor take care of your kin and
kith and your kind to others so with
these qualities there's no way that God
would disgrace you and then she took him
to her cousin Monica and often and
is a variable so interesting talking bit
nice to me we're gonna take a break and
we're gonna now they went to go see
another judeo-christian someone who knew
the scriptures
who knew that what the qualities would
be of a messenger and we're gonna hear
what this person had to say about the
problem Hamid peace be upon him we'll be
right back here on the Deen show
bismillah alhamdulillah Salam alaikum
peace be with you
this wee lad hamdulillah Salaam aleikum
peace be unto you Allah alhamdulillah
Salam alaikum bismillah alhamdulillah
Salam aleikum peace be unto you welcome
to the Dijon bismillah alhamdulillah
Salam alaikum peace be with few
greetings of peace to everybody all
around the globe that's tuning in to the
D shop back here on the D show with
sheikh sudan we're talking about the
last and final messenger sent to mankind
who was sent as a mercy to the world and
hopefully people get stimulated to
really look into his life now we before
we left he went to his wife she listed
all the good qualities
she basically testified to his
impeccable character and then she went
to go see the her cousin who was it like
a judeo-christian correct what he saying
he was a scholar in this and when did
you the wife of the Prophet SAW said she
took the Prophet SAW said him to him and
he said that this is an embassy said
that would which is this is the same
thing that has been revealed to Prophet
Musa and he referred to Moses peace be
upon him because of the similarity of
the message of Musa Musa al-salaam and
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him with
legislations and rulings and so on and
then he told them knowing the ways of
Allah subhanAllah because of what's been
mentioned in the previous books that you
people will drive you out and he said I
wish I would be strong and healthy when
your people drive you out so that I can
support you and give you a victory so
the Prophet peace be upon him he said my
people who drive me out he said yes
there's nobody came with what you came
with this message unless his people had
enmity against him and then very soon
after that welcome the knoefel he died
he passed away
Festo it is a Muslim he believed he
immediately accepted the message of the
Prophet SAW said Allah because of what
he hurt on the Prophet SAW solemn this
is such an immediate thing because of
his knowledge of course
that's amazing so another testimony and
he also accepted Islam immediately yes
and this is people can go look this up
right this is profound let's go into
another story chief rabbi scholar of the
Jews he also had an encounter he was
they were obviously in that area that
region for for because they're waiting
for a prophet
what did he do when he heard about the
Prophet Mohammed this was in Medina
after the Prophet SAW said migrated
toward Medina and his name is Abdullah
bin Salam and he was the chief rabbi of
the Jews and he embraces them and he
became a Muslim and when he embraced the
Dean of al-islam and he the Prophet SAW
said let me had a group of the Jews with
him and he said to our blood me Selim
hide so then after he did that the
Prophet s lmst who do you think what do
you say about Abdullah masala you chief
they said he is the best of us and he's
the son of the best of us and they
praised him so much so then the Prophet
SAW seldom told him to come out and he
said they she headed to them that he
became a Muslim he said there's no one
worthy of worship except Allah spinel to
Allah and that Prophet Muhammad is the
final Messenger of Allah immediately
they said he is the worst of us and he
is the son of the worst of us so this
which shows how unfair they were when
before they said that he is the best
person among them so the best person
embraced Islam and followed the prophets
of the body that's a maybe a scholar a
rabbi accepts Islam amazing so much more
to discuss you know we really want to
just give people a like a taste test but
what was now before we end and conclude
what was this this call that was
something pragmatic that it fit what
what the human being has inside him to
identify you know it wasn't something
farcical something weird bizarre let's
talk about just briefly in the last two
minutes we have this simple message that
was understandable it was believable
talk to us about it and that's the
miracle of all the message of the
messengers people think that they're
waiting for miracles to have
physically no it's something that has to
touch each and every one of us and we
need to really take the matter seriously
and to be sincere a messenger sent from
God he has nothing to do with his own
self is calling people to worship the
creator of the heavens and the earth
alone did not glorify me do not worship
Me do not think of me anything anything
but a human being
but the messenger of the creator of the
heavens and the earth worship Him alone
turn to him I don't put your trust in
him be obedient to him and then when you
see the revelation and the orders and
what is permissible what's not
permissible a perfect way of life the
best manners that he call people to to
adopt and he headed himself he did not
someone that was being a king or seeking
the wealth of others or seeking status
he lived and he slept on the ground to
the extent of which that the mattress
made of straws would make mark on his
side area so to say he was offered to be
the king and to have so much wealth to
live the to to leave this he refused and
he continued to to live the simple life
sometimes he would tie two stones and
his stomach out of the hunger and his
whole entire house would not even have a
piece of date in it this is the design
that he was someone that's doing things
only for the sake of Allah subhanAllah
calling people to the most very basic to
their nature that they are they having
the urge to it and I believe everybody's
watching us you have the urge in this
that if you believe in God alone worship
Him alone and this is what the messenger
how do you sort of said I'm he called
the people too and then you have the
best example in him in all of your
affairs and all of your life what is
more beautiful than this and how easy
that is for people to follow the truth
so before we leave and conclude so if
you accept Muhammad peace be upon as a
last and final messenger that
automatically includes Jesus Moses a
brand all the preceding messengers right
because if you just believe in one
messenger you just believe in the one
that sent them so if you disbelieve in
Jesus is that a ticket to the Hellfire
take you outside the fold of the truth
take the person to the halfway believe
this believing in Moses there's
believing in any of them of the
messengers that God sent to humanity so
we can safely say I mean look for the
people that you know tune in for the
first time before we go we love Jesus we
love them more than we love our own
sense
amazing thank you these builders you'd
think you said I would like a look like
I said I thought of it and there you
have it just a glimpse into his life
hopefully this has been enough to
stimulate you to look a little bit
further and do something real real real
easy ask the Creator to guide you that's
the first step we always recommend that
people ask not anyone not putting an
intermediary between you and the Creator
ask the Creator to guide you and do some
homework if you're like most people you
get caught up with the rat race of life
and you go from one party to the next
and TVs numb in your mind and music but
there's something more important you
know think about the day you're gonna
expire from this life and you'll be in
the great scary thing you don't want to
talk about it people make jokes about
and just change the topic but it's a
reality we're gonna die and doesn't
matter how many championships you want
how much of the millions trillions and
some of people work sweat like dogs and
work work work and they don't even
accomplish that and then you die and
then you just lose the next life in the
next slice forever it's paradise but you
have to plant seeds of goodness in this
life develop yourself to be the best
human being possible but you can't just
do it on your whims and desires you got
to follow the blueprint that the crater
sent down through all the messengers of
God and you got to learn about the last
and final messenger so do what's in your
very nature testify that it is nothing
worthy of worship except the crater that
Heather's in Arif and Muhammad is His
Messenger just like Jesus Moses Abraham
they were all messengers of God and when
you do this and you live by it
paradise is yours that's right paradise
is yours and you avoid the Hellfire to
do it right now call this number you
might have some some questions that are
just tickling you inside ask them tough
questions but do the work don't go back
to the to the war games grand theft auto
and then you just forget about all these
serious things 1 800 662 Islam call
right now let's see if you're brave
enough tough enough come on call ask the
tough questions and see what happens a
whole new world of goodness opens up for
you we'll see you next time here in Deen
show make sure to follow us on Twitter
like us on Facebook and we'll see you
next time here on the Deen show until
then peace be unto you